[Music]  few hours of the day are more important  than the early morning hours  one of the great thinkers said the first  hour is the rudder of the day it sets  the tone for everything else that  happens these hours when you first wake  up set the tone for the rest of the day  affecting your mindset and productivity  during all the hours that follow them  plan your day the night before  planning out your day the night before  may not exactly be part of your morning  routine but it is a great way to get  your day started off right in fact i was  just reading the story of a very  successful self-made multi-millionaire  multi-business developer who said every  single morning he starts off by reading  his goals every morning he never misses  a single day by planning out what you  want to accomplish the night before you  can start off each day with a plan in  mind rather than waking up unsure what  it is you want to tackle first